welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this
episode were breaking down some of the
best Easter eggs and Captain Marvel the
movie was the first female solo film in
the entire franchise and no it doesn't
feature any of the other major Marvel
movie heroes beyond a select few
there's still a lot of things and tying
to the overall universe that you only
notice after several watches throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking down
the movie's best Easter eggs the tiny
hints inner that symbolized what
direction the character is heading
towards and just some cool things that
you might have missed there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet then I
highly recommend that you check out now
please subscribe to the channel for a
Marvel movie breakdown every week and
don't forget to drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the content without the way thank
you for clicking this and let's get into
our breakdown of Captain Marvel
okay so spider-man far from home clearly
set up the webhead is the next Iron Man
in the wake of his death at the end of
Avengers endgame not only did Peter end
up receiving the Edith glasses from the
character he also became allies with
happy got access to his tech whilst
happy got access to his aunt and I think
it's hard to deny that he now holds the
position as the next Tony Stark there
was a lot of iconography that carried
across to the movie and overall you'd
have to be trapped in one of Mysterio's
illusions not to see it so we now have
the repulsive boots of the metal man
filled but that leaves one big question
who's going to be taking over from
Captain America obviously Sam Wilson is
currently vying for the position but in
the meantime I do think that Marvel are
actually setting up the role as Carol
being the leader and they've already
teased this in Captain Marvel these
shots side by side all symbolized the
similarities and how things are
currently being set up and it's hard to
deny that with this foreshadowing Kara
is going to be taking the position of
cap in the team even a nickname is cup
not only did they train under similar
circumstances they also done similar
clothing in their military uniform when
going incognito and even the design of
their suits is very similar the blue and
star symbols are a nice little mirroring
of the future and past of the position I
can definitely see this hinting out a
lot of things go
ahead so we can take that if Peter is
going to be playing the role of the next
iron man then Carol will be his opposite
in the team who knows we may even get a
civil war too that revolves around the
pair these shots aren't the only Captain
America Easter eggs either as when Carol
visits the ball we see hanging up in one
of the photo frames is the YB 49 this
plane was the basis for the design of
the hydroplane that we saw in Captain
America the First Avenger and the sit
hammers harm the ties between Carol and
the captain the bar is a tribute to the
happy bottom riding club which was a
hangout for pilots in the Mojave Desert
the film The Right Stuff also featured a
bar that was paying tribute to it and
when Carol crash lands on earth we see a
pickup of videotape which is actually
the film the right stuff itself is about
test pilots that are sent off on various
space missions and this of course
mirrors Carol whose final job at project
Pegasus involved a flying experimental
aircraft that had the ability to go into
space speaking of project Pegasus the
movie isn't the first time it makes an
appearance in the MCU originally it
popped up in a deleted scene in Iron Man
2 before making a fully fledged
appearance at the beginning of the
Avengers we actually see a sign for
project Pegasus in the opening of this
movie and the base that Carol visits in
the film is the same location that we
see destroyed at the start of that movie
Carol also searches who rides a Pegasus
in the film and though not mentioned
specifically this could be a nod to
Valkyrie who of course rides one and
thor ragnarok and n gain the bar also
contains a cool little easter egg and
that is the street fighter two cabinet
shoutouts to how did that FAP in on
reddit for noticing that if you look at
the game you can see m.bison doing his
psycho crusher move for a split second
this is very similar to captain Marvel's
primary fault an attack that she does
towards the end of the movie where she
shines with energy before blasting
through something speaking of Photon
this is also Maria Rambo's callsign on a
jet in the comics Rambo's daughter
actually becomes a hero named Photon so
this is a nice little callback now the
film is packed with other characters
that feature prominently in the MCU
firstly is Agent Coulson
who of course stars an agents of shield
agents of shield did use an inhibitor
device similar the one that we see on
Carol's neck
the film so is possible that they got
this idea from her we also see the
heroes in the film using the quad jet
which is actually a precursor to the
Quinn jet which is used both in the MCU
and agents of shield Nick Fury of course
features prominently in the film and
there's also a really interesting line
that he drops at one point in the movie
when talking to al Capitan he tells her
that his friends call him fury and his
enemies call him Nick be cast your mind
back to Winter Soldier Alexander Pierce
actually calls him Nick instead of fury
and this is a nice little tease as he
does turn out to be the bad guy in that
movie Nick had ignored my direct order
and carried out an unauthorized military
operation on foreign soil he saved the
lives of a dozen political officers
including my daughter so you gave him a
promotion I've never had any cause to
regret captain why was Nick in your
apartment last night
Maria Hill also calls fury Nick and
because of this fans of the arize that
she may have been a scroll this entire
time yikes
speaking of reaches its reach time so in
the film nick tells Carole that he can't
eat toast that's being cut diagonally
however in age of Ultron we see him
doing this hinting that he may have in
fact been a scroll similar to what we
saw at the end of far from home which
ties directly into this bone tomb I
always wondered how Nick I'm sorry fury
was able to get shot with a high-power
rifle in Winter Soldier and survived
however if he was indeed a scroll then
his resurrection makes more sense again
it's a bit of a reach but the other
movies and instances of his appearance
in the MCU definitely need a second look
over in the wake of far from home fury
said the last time that he trusted
someone he lost an eye and we see in the
film that he tells a goose II trust to
him before this happens also goose might
actually be able to tell when someone is
real and someone is simply a scrolling
disguise at one point when Carolyn Fury
meet the cute little cat sorry I mean
Fleur Caen it runs to their legs later
in the movie when talus is disguised as
a Greek god it does the same thing to
him showing that it recognizes him as an
eye and it is possible that Fleur
consents through other means instead of
just cite some other little cool tidbits
in the film and that when Maria is being
chased by Minerva
he takes a shortcut to get ahead and
this is a callback to how Carol would
often take shortcuts when the two used
to race one another this is mentioned at
the midpoint of the movie when they
discuss how Carol cheated in order to
win the chance to fly the new plane and
it's nice that it's brought back at the
end so that Maria can win for once
another big question is who young raagh
actually sees when he looks at the
supreme intelligence though never stated
in the film we did learn from deleted
scenes that he saw himself we do
discover that the person you see is the
person that you respect the most and
this speaks to the size of his ego along
with yon rug appear other Kree forces
such as Koroth and ronan who both pop up
in guardians of the galaxy in addition
to this Captain Marvel bills on the
style of guardians by using a lot of
similar iconography to the film to show
how the Galactic Marble adventures will
be going hex points are used in both
films to jump across the galaxy and we
see this in Captain Marvel and guardians
of the galaxy part 2 the way that the
names of planets and locations are
displayed are exactly the same in both
films and they contain their coordinates
in space Universal translators are
mentioned in the movie and we actually
discovering guardians that this was
implanted in each person's neck so that
they could understand all aliens the
masks and the way that they go of the
characters and guardians is also very
similar to how they work in Captain
Marvel and it's nice that this
consistency is kept up across all the
movies goose swallows the tesseract in
the film and I think this is a callback
to the Avengers when Bruce asks if fury
just wants him to swallow it the movie
doesn't just reference Marvel properties
either and there's actually a nice
little Natasha slam in there too
when Carole is selecting her new uniform
colors we can actually see a red and
gold one which are typically the colors
associated with the character in case
you don't know Shazam was initially
called Captain Marvel and DC actually
sued for the name
they won the bountiful prize of four
million dollars but since then they've
kind of gravitated towards using Shazam
instead of Captain Marvel I actually
agree with them on that
Shazam Suns way cooler than Captain
Marvel don't at me
just I am anyway that's our list
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the breakdown and if we missed
anything that you think should have made
it comment below and let us know and
make sure you check out our analysis of
Spider Man into the
spider-verse which talks about the best
Easter eggs in the movie so one of our
greatest videos ever so I definitely
recommend that you check it out after
this you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month and
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate you it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you only come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below
every month we give away free movies to
be bless subscribe to the channel and
this month eco on the Marvel phase 3
port do box and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the more
video is he coming on the more of a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved there when it's gonna be chosen
at random and the 15th of June and the
cell be shipped out from then to ever
get surprised so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]